[Music]
in the spring of 1974 a large brush fire
swept across the property owned by
Antoine and Jerry Betts while assessing
the damage they noticed something very
out of place lying in the smoldering
grass was a highly polished metal sphere
this became known as the BET sphere or
the bets orb Antoine and Jerry's 21 year
old son Terry Betts went to pick up the
spear although it was only eight inches
in diameter it was extremely heavy then
the Betts family did something with the
sphere that would change their lives
forever something that the family would
come to regret they brought it home
foreign
[Music]
family's property was on Fort George
Island just outside of Jacksonville
Florida and this wasn't the
stereotypical Florida family in the
woods the BET's property was 88 acres of
land mostly used for raising trees for
Timber Antoine betz was a marine
engineer his wife Jerry was an artist
and they had six children the vet's home
was essentially a mansion that the
family nicknamed The Castle the betses
were educated and well to do they were
not fortune and fame Seekers the BET's
fear was just under 8 inches in diameter
and weighed about 21 pounds so slightly
smaller than a bowling ball but much
heavier the sphere had no seams no weld
marks no signs of Machining it had a few
scuffs and scratches but no other dents
or damage it did have a three millimeter
triangle that was etched or stamped into
it the sphere didn't seem dangerous so
Terry brought it home and set it on his
windowsill with some other Collectibles
and nobody really thought much about it
but a few weeks later that would change
Terry and her friend were were in his
room playing guitar when they noticed a
humming sound coming from somewhere they
stopped playing listen for the hum and
it faded away after a minute they
Shrugged and went back to playing the
humming returned Terry walked around his
room strumming the guitar he soon
realized the sphere would vibrate along
with the notes he played he played a
little louder the sphere vibrated more
powerfully and then started buzzing at
this point the family dog started
whining as if disturbed by the sound
Terry decided to try a couple of
experiments he gently tapped the spear
with a hammer and it responded with a
ringing sound the way this fear reacted
to sound fascinated Terry so he grabbed
it took it out to the living room to
show his family everyone gathered around
then Terry set the ball down and went to
grab his hammer and his guitar though
nobody was touching the sphere or even
near it it started to move on its own
foreign
just an interesting souvenir found in
the woods it had extraordinary
properties it responded to sound to
touch and now had the power of a
Locomotion when the BET sphere was
rolled across the ground it would roll
away stop vibrate and then change
directions it would then stop vibrate
change directions again and come back to
the person who rolled it sometimes it
rolled for just a few seconds but
sometimes for up to five minutes once it
rolled for 12 minutes on its own before
it finally came to a stop at first the
betses thought it could be a gyroscope
which would account for the movement
gyroscopes don't chase people scare
portals or play guitar no but I respect
them for being skeptical so they put the
sphere on this coffee table that had a
glass top they pushed it it would not
fall off it would roll around the edge
of the table then to the middle and just
stop it had to be freaking out by now
right they were but what happened next
is bananas they lifted one end of the
table to get it to roll onto the floor
it didn't it rolled up the incline as if
trying to save itself from falling
it seemed to be Jerry picked up the
sphere and started shaking it it didn't
like this in a newspaper report Jerry's
quoted as saying if you shake the ball
vigorously and then place it on the
ground it feels just like a huge Mexican
jumping beam which is trying to get away
from you the bets has figured out that
the sphere had a magnetic field a paper
clip would stick to it but could be
removed easily but if the sphere spent a
lot of time rolling the magnetic field
got stronger after rolling around for a
few minutes the lid from a mayonnaise
jar stuck to it and they couldn't pry it
off they thought maybe it could be solar
powered the Spheres seemed to be more
active when exposed to sunlight when set
in the sun they could feel a gentle
vibration and hear a low hum as if there
was a motor inside when they brought the
sphere back inside it stayed warm for
three entire days after a few days of
this a family friend reached out to the
Jacksonville Journal who reluctantly
sent a photographer that photographer
arrived a skeptic but he left a believer
Lon anger was a long time photographer
for the Jacksonville Journal he'd seen
it all when he arrived at the BET's home
he admitted this to Jerry I'm weary of
this kind of thing when I got there Mrs
betz said you won't believe this if you
don't see it they told me to put the orb
on the floor and give it a push it
rolled aways and stopped so what just
wait a minute then it turned by itself
then rolled about four feet it stopped
then it turned again and rolled to the
left about eight feet made a big Arc and
came right back to my feet the
photographer was convinced the paper ran
the story and the BET sphere became an
overnight sensation journalists from all
over the world were calling for
interviews now in the 70s there was no
call waiting you either got through or
you didn't and after the story went out
it was almost impossible for calls to
get through we came to Fort George
Island to get away to a Serene
atmosphere now he can't get away from
the telephone it means nothing to people
in the west that it's midnight here and
when they quit calling those in the
Eastway up and start the betses were not
that interested in giving interviews but
they did want to help identifying the
sphere finally A call came through that
would be difficult for the bets family
to ignore
again that's the first thing
named uncle and the last name rhyme with
Sam yep the United States military
wanted to have a look of course they did
still Jerry said no this annoyed the
government anybody
's okay in my book mine too but the US
government wouldn't take no for an
answer
[Music]
with all the media coverage surrounding
the sphere the military wanted to have a
look Jerry was reluctant to let them
have it but there was concern that the
sphere could be unexploded ordinance so
Jerry agreed to loan it to the Navy for
two weeks but if it was determined that
it wasn't military property she wanted
it returned she even made the Navy sign
a contract I told them we expect a
comprehensive report in two weeks and if
it can't be identified as government
property it is to be returned to US Navy
scientists performed a number of tests
they measured it at exactly 7.96 inches
in diameter and it weighed 21.34 pounds
the shell was made of some kind of
magnetic stainless steel alloy it could
withstand extreme heat and extreme
pressure of a hundred and twenty
thousand pounds per square inch this
thing was tough according to the
spectrograph it was made of stainless
steel grade 431 the Navy also found that
the sphere was intensely magnetic it had
four magnetic poles two positive and two
negative the magnetic fields varied in
strength and were in an unusual pattern
the next test was X-rays and that's
where they ran into a little snag our
first x-ray attempts got us nowhere
we're going to use a more powerful
machine on it and also run spectrograph
tests to determine what metal it's made
of there's certainly something odd about
it the X-rays showed nothing so at the
end of the two weeks the Navy confirmed
that it wasn't government property and
wasn't dangerous so it was returned to
the BET's family but something strange
happened next a Navy serviceman came to
the BET's house to return the object he
was also carrying a manila envelope and
even though the Navy said they were
unable to x-ray the sphere that envelope
contained x-rays the images showed the
entire internal structure of the sphere
the images also showed there was
something inside
foreign
the results of the x-rays were
surprising the sphere had an outer shell
that was about half an inch thick inside
the sphere were different layers of
Steel of different densities at the core
of the sphere about the size of an apple
was a hollow space and in that space
were three other smaller spheres and
each of them had tiny wires attached one
mystery was what are these other objects
inside the sphere but an even bigger
mystery how did they get in there
typically you'd get objects into a
sphere by either cutting it in half then
sealing it or drilling out a hole and
placing the objects in that way but
there was no hole and no seam even Navy
scientists couldn't figure it out the
Navy wanted to drill into it but Jerry
said no way now during all this
excitement friends and neighbors and
people in the media were suggesting that
the sphere could be extraterrestrial
because it responded to sound had a
magnetic field and was almost
indestructible some people speculated it
was an alien listening device the betses
didn't give much Credence to these
theories until the Navy came back with
nothing if no other explanation can be
found that's as logical as any who could
say what's on another planet even
speculations have been proven wrong the
Navy says what it isn't they say it
isn't an explosive so we still want to
know what it is so the bets has reached
out to scientists for answers what the
scientists found created even more
questions
[Music]
the first scientists to examine the
sphere was Dr Carl Williston of the
Omega minus one Institute he spent six
hours running tests and one of his
strangest discoveries was that the
sphere was emitting radio waves he also
confirmed the Navy's findings of four
poles but like the Navy he couldn't
explain the pattern of the magnetic
fields it defied the laws of physics he
also witnessed the sphere moving on its
own across any surface Dr Williston
confirmed the exterior was made of
stainless steel grade 431 but he also
found traces of an extremely heavy but
unknown element and a side note about Dr
Williston there isn't any evidence that
anyone by that name ever existed and the
Omega minus one Institute is also a bit
of a mystery some have speculated that
he was a foreign operative Gathering
Intelligence on the object the next
scientist the bets brought in was Dr
James Harder he was an engineering
professor and became a trusted advisor
to the family Dr harder confirmed Dr
williston's findings and said the
internal spheres were made of a material
with an atomic number of 140 an atomic
number is the number of protons an
element has the highest atomic number
that occurs in nature is 92 uranium it
is possible to artificially increase the
number of protons but the highest
scientists have been able to achieve is
118 protons so the element found in the
sphere does not occur on Earth this led
Dr harder to wonder if the sphere could
be a damaged Alien Probe or anti-gravity
device the next scientist was Dr J Allen
heineck he was a well-known astronomer
and Professor but Dr heideck was best
known for being a UFO advisor to the U.S
Air Force under three separate projects
including Project Blue Book which
investigated UFOs from 1952 to 1969. and
probably longer and probably longer and
probably still and probably still Dr
heineck also confirmed the findings of
the other scientists and during this
time of chaotic activity something
happened that made the bets family very
nervous a group of scientists flew into
Jacksonville arrived at the BET's home
and offered Jerry 750 000 cash for the
sphere that would be worth almost four
million dollars today well nil because
of inflation eh yep and next year
that'll be six million because of
inflation I really hope you're wrong
about that I am not anyway there was
something about these guys that rubbed
Jerry the wrong way when they asked to
see the sphere she said it wasn't there
and turned down their cash offer this
really annoyed the men and after they
left the family checked their backstory
turns out it was all a lie the family
suspected this was probably a foreign
government trying to acquire the sphere
and that's when the bets family realized
they were in danger
in the 1970s The National Enquirer
offered a cash award to anyone who could
prove that there is life on other
planets even though the Inquirer was a
bit of a rag the UFO panel they
assembled contained a lot of
well-respected people heineck and harder
were on the panel but there were also
multiple PhD holders a former Supreme
Court Justice and a former United States
Attorney General the bets family decided
to send Terry and the sphere to this
Gathering they didn't necessarily think
the object was from outer space but they
figured with all these experts in one
place they could finally get some
answers after spending some time with
the sphere Dr heineck felt it was
man-made though everyone witnessed the
sphere roll up a piece of Plexiglas from
a dead stop nobody could explain that
when the idea of drilling came back up
Dr harder warned that if the sphere
contained material with an atomic number
as high as 140 drilling into it could
cause it to go critical
what do you mean critical at that time
the only way to create elements with an
atomic number higher than 92 was with a
nuclear reactor the protons within the
sphere are much higher than anything
ever discovered or created so drilling
into it okay make it go boom right but
the story takes another turn while at
the inquirer's office Terry got a call
that said his mother had an accident
Terry tried to call her but couldn't get
through so he flew back immediately with
the ball I hope nope he left it behind
when Terry got home Jerry was fine
someone was trying to separate Terry
from the sphere Jerry told her son to go
back to the Inquirer immediately and get
it so he did at first The Inquirer
didn't cooperate they gave him a story
and seemed to be stalling so Terry
demanded it be returned they finally
admitted that they couldn't return it it
was gone
eventually the people at The Enquirer
admitted that the UFO panel had taken
the sphere to New Orleans to run further
tests so Terry drives down there and
when he arrives the sphere is being
guarded by the Navy they tell Terry that
while the sphere is being tested he's
not allowed to go near it his property I
know that's a bunch of bulls it is the
test didn't reveal anything new so after
a lot of arguing Terry was finally able
to get the sphere back as Terry is
leaving the facility a few reporters ask
if he can make this fear do something
Terry says sure every time you set it
down it rolls all over the place in fact
the bets has kept the sphere in a
bowling bag at home because it wouldn't
stay still so Terry sets the sphere down
and nothing it's not vibrating it's not
humming it's not moving it's not doing
anything so Terry leaves a little later
Terry gets a hold of his sister who
tells him that there are people not
reporters waiting for him at the airport
so Terry just drives home once back in
Florida the family has the sphere
examined and x-rayed again it no longer
had four magnetic poles and the X-rays
showed that the sphere now had a seam
which wasn't there before hey someone
pulled the old Switcheroo yep that's
what they believe and the interior
doesn't have three small spheres anymore
just dust and Dr harder warned the BET's
family to be careful harder didn't trust
Dr heineck and thought maybe heineck had
something to do with the sphere being
replaced and I want to mention that
years later after Dr heineck passed away
his son Paul mentioned that the family
had a silver sphere all they knew about
it was that their father said it had
something to do with a UFO case in
Florida it was stolen by Dr Heine heinek
what did there's no proof that he stole
it but it's quite a coincidence that
after heinek was left alone with the
sphere suddenly it stopped working then
a different sphere also from Florida
shows up at Dr heineck's House so all
this became too much for the Betts
family they were constantly being
hounded by the press and followed by
what they thought were government agents
once Jerry was even physically assaulted
by someone who pretended to be a
repairman so the BET's family quickly
and quietly faded back into society they
sold their house and left the island
they gave no more interviews they wrote
no books no movies they they wanted
nothing more to do with the sphere Now
Jerry is still around and has a Blog
where she showcases her artwork and
tells the story of her life nowhere does
she mention anything about the BET
sphere so the BET's family never got the
answer that they wanted the answer we
all want what is the BET sphere
there are a few theories about the
betsphere one is that it's a down
satellite or piece of space junk it's a
plausible Theory but if the sphere was a
piece of technology it would probably
have a seam and connectors but it has
none of these another theory is that
it's a foo fighter hello I've waited
here for you ever
[Music]
yo what Foo Fighters I know the song but
may I yeah go ahead with the story about
your alien balls during World War II
Allied aircraft encountered UFOs that
followed them and were able to move at
incredible speeds the pilots gave the
UFOs the nickname Foo Fighters poo is
just a fun meaningless word another
theory is that it's an alien Atomic
weapon people who believe this Theory
think that this was one of the weapons
that was used to destroy Atlantis and
there could be clues that ancient
nuclear weapons did exist in the world's
oldest epic the Mahabharata a line
mentions a terrifying weapon a single
projectile charged with all the power of
the universe an incandescent column of
smoke and Flame is bright as 10 000 Suns
Rose in all its Splendor a more mundane
explanation is that the BET sphere was
just a piece of industrial equipment an
artist named James Durling Jones said he
lost the sphere a few years earlier he
had been collecting scrap metal for use
in sculptures darling Jones said it was
a ball check valve used as a flow
regulator in large pipes he said it fell
from the rack on top of his Volkswagen
bus this is the most widely accepted
Theory you trust this dirty hippie be
nice sorry you trust this dirty artist
well a couple of problems with it being
from a valve there's only one Factory on
the island a paper mill though they do
use balls like this in valves they only
weigh about seven or eight pounds the
BET sphere weighs 21 pounds and remember
the sphere was found in the woods it was
about a mile away from the nearest Road
sure the sphere could move on its own
but a mile seems like a long way for it
to roll now some claim this fear didn't
roll on its own at all the bets's home
had uneven tile floors and the sphere
which was perfectly balanced was just
rolling around on the tile now that
doesn't explain why it would come back
to the same person who rolled it now to
be fair when the Navy was testing it
they never saw it roll on its own but
plenty of other people did Robert
Edwards president of a local Supply
Company showed her reporter a brand new
stainless steel ball manufactured by
Bell Howell it was eight inches across
and weighed just over 21 pounds same as
the BET sphere Elks I don't think so the
vet's family had plenty of money and
aside from trying to win the prize from
The National Enquirer they never tried
to profit from it they could have made a
fortune selling books about the spear
especially when it was international
news they didn't and to this day nobody
really knows what the BET sphere is it
was taken by the Navy or by Dr heineck
we may never know it's very possible
that the most significant scientific
discovery ever made is sitting in an old
bag Gathering dust in someone's basement
somewhere and the only way we'll ever
learn the secret of the BET sphere is
when its owner whoever he or she is
decides they want to take up bowling
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's Heckle
fish this has been the y-files if you
had butter learned anything do us a
favor and like comment subscribe share I
know it's annoying but that stuff really
helps the channel like most topics we
cover here this one was recommended by
you and if there's a story you'd like to
see or learn more about go to the
yfiles.com tips and special thanks to
our patrons who make this channel
possible I couldn't do this without you
if you'd like to support the channel
consider becoming a member on patreon or
grabbing something from the Wi-Fi store
approaches goes to a good cause what
causes that my vodka fund but it causes
any
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]